tout un petit boulot très longtemps toi
kervennic hervé lycée en fait faut
séparer en deux mots naquet le coeur
parce que pour nous la musique c'est ça
c'est un partage ces îles sont du coeur
il faut qu'ils arrivent dans dans le
code de moon aussi et velits velits
c'était pour l'étoile donc là un petit
peu le destin qui a fait que la
réunissent et ses cinq ballons là
[Musique]
schizophrène de la musique comme lady
très rattaché au maloya mais très très
très aussi intéressé par tout ce qui est
musique du monde et même le classique et
justement ma main est un amoureux du
violon violoncelle et du coup nadia l'on
mette ensemble et c'était pour le prix
du 20 décembre et notamment voyez moi
gros coup de bluff deux chansons avec
guitare avoir vent dans les affaires que
n'aurait de violon violoncelle rouler à
tout ça n'est en aucun musicien et nous
a été retenue donc à partir de ce
moment-là fallait chercher les gars est
très rapidement constitué une première
équipe a fait le prix le 20 décembre
ça va bien se passer adivalor
continu-continu pas jusqu'à
[Musique]
maloya pas comme on l'a sorti cet album
là dedans me composent aimiez crime et
nina aussi d'autres membres du groupe
qui emmène notre grain de sel
c'est toi alors
les taux souvent ma partie théâtre
théâtre de saint-gilles souvent
aventures d d d d artistes comiques mis
à dos et me regarder avec des ultimes en
mayenne il était dans un jour
pourvu que ce soit - et là c'est
l'apothéose transporter les gens dans
notre univers il a deux pour tous les
geeks on peut aller sur le lieu de la
valse ou peut aller sur ceux du maloya
où peut aller sur des morceaux cela mes
enfants là nous espère même des étoiles
dans les yeux des gens n'y pensent que
vous êtes au ciment cazottes de voir un
petit spectacle haussier donc on va
essayer de faire en sorte que tout ça
ils cohabitent ensemble
[Musique]
depuis que ma vie ici
mais pour le temps imaginé le sable ou
bon sens est la laisse pour moi c'est
comme ça tu la mer
ils s'en battent dans mon cap cap la
poupée tenta boc simon
[Musique]